it's a critical year for tackling
climate change and the government is
committed to reaching Net Zero by 2050
but how much will coronavirus impact
what many believed would be a green
budget the Court of Appeal recently
ruled against a third runway at Heathrow
saying ministers had failed to take into
account the UK's commitment to tackle
global warming now campaigners say the
government should put its money where
its mouth is and if it doesn't they'll
sue the Prime Minister so this is our
letter before claim or letter before
action they've launched similar legal
action to Heathrow challenging the
government's energy policies including
plans for a new gas power plant at Drax
in North Yorkshire the law of the land
is that you have to change your national
policy statements which determine how we
build energy infrastructure in line with
the changes that have been made in this
country so we got new carbon targets
we've signed the Paris agreement
Parliament has declared a climate
emergency oh yes and we've left the EU
none of that is currently reflected in
law in 2018 an estimated 18 percent of
carbon dioxide emissions in the UK were
generated by the residential sector 27%
of Aryans came from energy 18 percent
were generated by business and a third
33% of emissions were from transport
since 1990 transport emissions have
fallen just 3% lagging way behind other
sectors transport campaigners say they
too will consider taking the government
to court if it doesn't deliver for them
in the budget the only action we've seen
is that other small steps they've taken
around promoting electric vehicles
including buses but we haven't seen the
big steps that are needed like tackling
fuel duty freeze tackling the road
building programme and investing
significantly in proper cycling
facilities and much better buses
others believer fight in the courts
isn't the way to secure greater climate
commitments I think it's a useful
strategy but I think it might risk
derailing a government that's already
making progress on climate change and no
suing someone is usually not always get
to do what you want the government says
it's building momentum towards a carbon
0 economy environmentalists say in spite
of coronavirus radical budget
announcements are needed if Britain is
to lead the world on climate change Lisa
Holland Sky News